brown as we mentioned 20 points donovan
mitchell 12.
um shaq donovan mitchell looking good
i don't have down in the mitch i have
jaylen brown no i know but i'm just
saying that well yeah
listen listen hell of a player uh looks
really good and someone say that you
can't hate because of why
why can't i hate yeah why can't you i i
never hate i just trust you because
you're
set it up for the t-shirt i just try to
we're trying to sell merch here we're
trying to sell merch
i just try to give constructive
criticism and my whole career i've been
a leader
and i motivate my player a certain way
so you welcome utah well i was trying to
motivate you
because you told me that all the time
that you said underdog put it on a
t-shirt
oh yes they never did well guess what i
put it on underdog put it on a t-shirt
oh
get that underdog put it on a t-shirt
thank you underdog put on a t-shirt lift
it up shaq
oh too great to hate yes
no this large i need to exhale this
large thing a great stadium
let me get this nice appreciate that
underdog hey
adam tried to throw you a lob and i know
that's going to go back to constructive
criticism well adam should have
well adam should have told me that it
was a surprise
anyway jaylen brown let's get to that
now let's send it to adam lefkow
in atlanta as the jazz keep on rolling
[Music]
b.a you're the man kia post game show
best part about that is i get to turn to
the man on my right
just go hmm you're welcome
you're welcome you know what i'm doing
ever since i called them out cam there's
10 11 games in a row we got a tweet from
samson
donovan mitchell is shacked after this
performance are you not
there you go either way he was gonna be
right candace is not about being right
you think i have ego
it's about leading leaving your best
player to make them play at that next
level
you're welcome did the same thing to
d-wade in the finals when he had before
he just said it ain't about being right
right what i do
a baby game show and the tweets are
coming in and you are going to get a
rare shack tonight he is ready to go
donovan mitchell breaking action yes he
is snagging shoals
what the spider show and then the last
one caught shaq's attention
someone tell me why the jazz can't beat
the lakers
nba on tnt post game presented by kia no
comments
o'neil adam lefkow candace parker wait
wait
it will come in the highlights
best start in franchise history 20-5 how
about this they're now
16-4 in games decided by 10 points or
more
another solid game by jaylen brown but
the story really
is donovan mitchell and another big game
double double for rudy gobert some
tweets
shaq looking for a way out of the corner
he's backed himself into regarding
donovan mitchell
they're coming at you nick no they can't
come on monday donna mitchell patiently
waiting for that apology
i don't talk about the fifth best guard
in the league talk about steph got fifth
i said it
what's this right there candice you over
here looking what's the reason why is he
always coming down here because you're
looking at me crazy i mean what's his
rank
lizzie had a great game night but what's
his ranking in the league i want to
focus on that last tweet that you want
to talk about which is
why can't why can't they beat the lakers
they're 20 and five they have the best
record in the west and i think everybody
including yourself is going
when it's playoff time it doesn't matter
is there any way that this team you
think can compete for a championship
yeah they listen they're looking really
good
donovan's playing great little bears
playing great that everybody's touching
the ball
clarkson coming out the bench giving
that great energy they have
a chance to do it but will they do it
can they do it
only time will tell listen i'm i'm
hoping for him
you know i i challenge him because i
wanted him to get to that next that
superstar level he's a star but
i want him to get to the level of the
guys that i play with so a lot of people
thought i was being serious and being
catty but i knew what i was doing as a
leader so
but are they ready for the lakers yet i
don't think they're
that close yes we're